how do you sum up milwaukee's season
kenny well um disappointing
i think you know even before the injury
they were down 3-3-0
you know to this team um so i think it
would be disappointing this is a team
that
had aspirations to win an nba title had
all the pieces best record for the
second straight year had
all the pieces in place last year
uh tasted uh you know getting to the
conference finals and
being so close and for me i think it
would just be disappointing because
if you look at if you look back and you
say
well where did they improve there wasn't
there wasn't one glaring area that said
this team got
better at this this year and so
i think that's where the disappointment
lies more than anything and ernie as a
player i could
we all can tell you especially when you
have a great season and then you have to
go home like that because now you have
to start
all over again so you know 50 games 60
games mvp
next year when the season starts none of
that matters now you have to start all
over
season recap for the milwaukee bucks as
we get to you
charles 56 and 16 with giannis five and
six without him they
won their first five lost their last six
when he did not play
and you see the notable contract
chris middleton and eric bledsoe three
plus years left on theirs and
the question again is giannis well
listen i hope giannis does like uh
michael jordan or dirk nowitzki don't
just be uh a chump and try to join
another organization battle through it
michael george just said i'm gonna get
better
uh dirk naviski said i'm just going to
keep getting better and they end up
winning the championship
you know i hope he doesn't become a
chump and just jump to another
organization
listen i think he got to i hope he signs
the max deal this summer and say i'm
going to win in milwaukee
you know i listen i could join a super
team and uh win
but i want to still have my own legacy
and identity
uh but i'm a kenny's right it's
disappointing
uh they did not get better i do think
they can learn
something from tonight in the last two
games
you know because for the last two years
they just get up all the yellows at the
top of the key
and let him go one-on-one and it works
when you're doing the regular season
where you're playing no disrespect
when you're playing the bulls orlando
you know the knicks teams like that you
can
win those games because you got more
talent but you play against a team like
toronto in the playoffs last year
the the the heat this year all your flow
flaws show but i thought the last two
games
i saw more movement i saw more ball
movement more body movement
and i don't understand why they don't
incorporate cooperate that throughout
the year
because your flaws don't really show
until you get to the playoffs against an
elite team
so uh i like to say i hope you're on the
stage i hope he signs that max deal this
summer